women are not meant to work 9 to 5 jobs
I said this before and I'll say it again
we shouldn't have to work 9 to 5 jobs
women are meant to go to Pilates class,
tan by a pool,
read a good book,
take care of the children,
make good food,
and be provided for by a man
there's no way a woman can be in her feminine energy
if she's sitting at a 9 to 5 job where she's unhappy
worst part is
is there's women out there that are
having to fill that masculine role in the office
because they have to be
they're covering bills
they're paying for half a dinner,
when a man should be paying for the job every time
when did we as a society
decide that women should go to a 9 to 5 job to feel some gratification
instead of staying at home with the kids.
if a woman wants to work part time
so she can spend more time with her kids at home
she should be able to do that
and don't get me wrong
if you wanna work a 9 to 5 job